hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game also from round one of
this year's fed Grand Swiss it is Ivan
chich versus Fabiano Carana they played
it on board one fabbi is the top seed of
the event as he is currently rated
number two in the world second only to
Magnus Carlson he is very very close to
Breaking 2800 again uh and reclaiming
his rightful place uh as a 2800 players
so here Ian has the white pieces
whenever we cover Ian's games you know
that he always attacks uh here it's
pretty much the same he really attacked
Fabby let's see what Fabby did even with
the white pieces opened with Pawn to E4
fa played Pawn to C5 he goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight F3 Pawn to D6
and D4 going for the open Sicilian uh
sorry about that uh we have C captures
on D4 Knight captures and now Knight to
F6 we have Knight C3 and A6 the Knight
of Sicilian is on the board and Evan
goes for Bishop to D3 one of the many
ways uh on how you can attack the the
Knight of Sicilian and usually E5 is the
top move then E6 and G6 probably like
the third most popular continuation is
what Fabi goes for uh we have F3
strengthening the uh E4 pawn and now
Bishop to G7 with Bishop to E3 the
standard um idea Queen to D2 is coming
and then you want to trade off your dark
Square Bishop for black strong Bishop on
G7 Knight B to D7 Queen to D2 and now
pon H5 uh sorry Pon H5 is a a known
movie was played in the game Leon Aran
versus Maxim Vash gra that ended in a
draw it was played this year uh in the
uh chess Global league but um here we
don't have H5 here we have Pawn to B5
going for Pawn to B4 so A4 and now there
is the game or a couple of games where B
captures on A4 was played but here we
have Pawn to B4 and it is now as of move
10 that we have a completely new game so
okay okay Knight C to E2 and Fabby
strikes in the center with Pawn to D5
leaving the B4 Pawn undefended but it's
uh very very hard to calculate this uh
over the board because if you capture uh
there are so many ways black can play
this you can go after the queen right
away you can just play Queen to C7 then
wait for white to make a move let's say
white goes Rook A3 wants to play Rook to
C3 you play D captures on e4 and after
let's say F captures as you don't want
to give up maybe your light Square
Bishop then you go Bishop to B7 then you
can play Rook to B8 so it's a very very
uh tricky uh tricky idea and especially
if Evan doesn't know what he's doing
obviously this is Fab's preparation
maybe he wants to avoid such a such a
sharp line so instead he goes for the
standard stuff Bishop to H6 he wants to
trade of the dark Square Bishops Bishop
captures we have Queen captures and now
D captures on e4 and now interestingly
even doesn't capture with the pawn he
captures with the bishop probably
because if he captures with the pawn uh
the Bishop basically becomes a pawn
let's say Bishop to B7 Newcastle and
once E5 is played this Pawn is now stuck
on e4 uh this bishop will be a pawn for
a very very long time so he decides to
give it up right away Bishop captures we
have Knight captures F captures and now
Queen to C7 putting some pressure on the
C2 Pawn if maybe E5 is played the Knight
is kicked away this could be an issue
and also if Queen to G7 is played
attacking The Rook maybe you don't even
have to play Rook to f8 with the queen
C7 you can even play Queen to E5 and
offer a queen trade for example captures
captures and black is very very happy
with his position uh so instead after
Queen to C7 even just castled and now
Knight to F6 preparing Knight to G4
where the Knight will be nicely defended
by the bishop you're going to kick away
the queen and then Castle to safety and
um it probably is the safest thing to do
for example C3 uh you go after the queen
let's say Knight to G4 Queen to H4 and
now even if Pawn to E5 attacking the
Knight Knight F3 now you can go Knight
to E3 you attack the rook and maybe even
some uh three-fold repetition is in the
works after uh such a maneuver uh but
even did not want to play Pawn to C3 or
go for some sort of a line like that he
played Rook captures on F6 he said all
right your king is in the center of the
board I'm going to give up the exchange
and also grab a pawn while I'm at it so
e captures on F6 and now Queen G7
attacking the rook and Pawn Rook to f8
and queen captures on F6 so obviously
this is not something that came as a
surprise to Fabby he had something
prepared for it and he just plays Bishop
to B7 and now what I meant by the title
of this video the king will constantly
be uh surrounded by the White Queen and
by these two knights and they will not
be able to touch the black king as
you'll see just to give you an example
E5 seems like a move you all want to
play E6 is coming looks uh looks
incredible but Queen to d8 always kicks
the queen away and now there's this very
nice freeing maneuver for black after
Queen to F2 you will play Queen to A5
you're going to go after the pawn and
once you defended once again Queen to F6
now you're going to play Queen to D5 and
threaten Checkmate and once you stop
that now the queen can no longer go back
to uh to to F3 and you're just going to
play Queen to d8 offer a queen trade now
Queen comes to F4 and you can play Queen
to B6 with check and now you are free to
Castle so let's say King H1 or you block
with the Knight Queen side castles and
your king is back in the game uh so
instead Shish went for Knight to F4 uh
also uh you you always want to have that
Knight to D5 move ready which if Bishop
captures you will be able to open up the
E file and then maybe Rook to E1 will be
able to do some damage uh but Fabby goes
Queen to d8 again Queen to E5 with check
and queen to E7 and this is now a
problem none of these squares are
available to your queen the only Square
you have have is the A5 Square so Queen
to A5 and now comes Rook to C8 this is
um the first maybe not uh uh a perfect
move played by Fabby and okay maybe we
can use or maybe even a suboptimal move
was played uh we can use such terms when
we talk about Fab's games is they are
always so incredibly precise uh here you
want to instead of Rook C8 you have to
play Queen to D6 first it would seem
because now if Knight to D5 which is
White's only remaining plan now Rook to
C8 is very strong and now if Rook to D1
let's say uh you will play Queen to C5
you offer a queen trade and uh you put
pressure on this Knight so there's
really nothing better you can either
trade here on B4 or trade queens and the
attack is over but Fabby played Rook to
C8 first and now he sort of gave even a
bit of a chance to get back into the
game but even missed it he played Knight
to D3 He went after the B4 Pawn right
away uh but uh Queen to B6 is the way at
to play this and also it takes away any
counterplay Fabby had with Ponto F5 as
was played in the game here if you play
Ponto F5 now Knight D5 is actually very
strong Bishop captures e captures and
now you have to worry about Knight to C6
Knight to E6 and then Rook to E1 so many
many um funny ideas and also probably
the most important thing in this line is
that Queen to E3 check you don't have to
worry about blundering a knight because
the queen is defending the knight from
B6 so Queen to B6 a great move uh uh you
know on on many fronts but okay Knight
to D3 was played and now Fabby played
Pawn to F5 and now you don't really uh
you don't really have a good reply to
this uh Knight to
F4 shage just brings the Knight back to
F4 but it's hard to make a move like if
he captures an F4 Queen to E3 check now
picks up the Knight as the queen is no
longer on B6 like in the other line
defending the Knight so instead after F5
Knight to F4 was played so bring it to
D3 then back to F4 maybe not the not the
most impressive way uh F captures on e4
now Fabby gets a pass pawn and also now
he gains more control over the D5 Square
he no longer has to worry about Knight
to D5 we have Knight F to E6 and now
Queen to F6 again incredible Queen and
two knights in front of the black king
and there is nothing to worry about now
uh you could go for this Knight to C7
check it does look impressive but that
just gets to Checkmate it black will
simply give up the rook and then play
Queen to F2 check of course you you have
all seen this back rank Checkmate so you
can play that so here H3 stopping all
sorts of nasty back rank ideas and now
Rook to F7 Fabby takes control over the
C7 square and that's pretty much it now
even just has to uh um you know decides
to play a lesser lesser game uh with
something like Queen captures on B4 then
comes Queen F2 check and after King to
H2 or H1 then E3 comes comes the bishop
opens up and it will be impossible to
defend this but he tried one last idea
Rook to E1 he gives up a full Rook now
Queen to F2 check can pick up the Rook
but it is the only way for him to get
the queen into the attack but look at
this queen to F2 check King to H2 Queen
captures on E1 and queen to E5 surely
now the two knights and queen can do
something against the black king in the
open board but not really just Rook to
E7 and there's no move if you play Queen
to h8 check just King D7 there's no
continuation Knight to f8 check you can
even pick up the Knight doesn't really
matter you'll play Queen to
D2 attack the Knight really no good
Square for the Knight then E3 is coming
then you just get checkmated there's
nothing to be done here so Knight to B3
was played by Ian and now Fabby just
played Queen to F2 and he was in this
position un move 30 that Ian chage
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh very nicely
done uh like I said other than Queen
Queen to h8 E3 is coming so there's
really no stopping that and also the
queen on F2 prevents the knight from
coming to C5 so that's also very
important U well like I said once you
give one more check King to D7 Queen to
D4 check you can even offer a queen
trade uh but white is just down too much
material uh it's it's two Rooks and a
bishop against two knights of course
it's not very uh very much even a
contest uh so yeah uh very nicely done
by by Fab very nicely done by Evan as
well the The Exchange sacrifice on F6
was very nice but at some point uh yeah
that there was that tricky Queen to B6
move that he could have tried uh but you
know it's incredibly complicated
position uh you you either find it or
you don't uh so yeah very nicely done by
Fabby uh in round two on board one Fabby
will be facing none other than Hans
mochen Neeman and Fabby is now very very
close to Breaking 2800 again he is
currently on 27
97.8 so two 2.2 uh more points uh he
needs to break 2800 and then not only
Magnus will be the only 2800 player in
the world so good luck to Fabby we'll
see how it goes uh he doesn't need to
win this to qualify he's already
qualified for the candidates tournament
so you know he's just playing chess and
you know if he breaks 2800 uh all all
the better uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank an anonymous person Daniel Taylor
Mark Baki grid words logical letters for
iOS and John gear law office L LC for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day